so our holiday courses are really aimed
at getting the students to speak they're
all learning English obviously at school
and they do have quite a bit of language
but what they really need is the
opportunity to use that language and to
get feedback on it from the teachers
we've introduced a drama component to
the secondary classes in the afternoon
largely because we know that the
students really enjoy it it provides an
opportunity for them to really practice
the language the structures they've
learnt in the morning in a more
practical way in the afternoon so that
rather than taking a more passive
approach to learning they're actively
involved in their own learning I find
it's cool because it may be more lively
than in school we we talk to each other
and it is a more funny way to learn
English and it's cool
expect for you to work with people and
to have different opinions on the same
play so it's like funny to work a script
together and he does
now either other features we look at the
story and read the story and then the
young learners decide on how they want
to present the story in terms of a
performance at the end of the week so we
get them to script it themselves
pick the themes from the story and then
they practice and then we have a
rehearsal on the Thursday and then we
perform it to the rest of the groups on
Friday and they get a lot out of that we
like to think of it more as practical
application at the language so it's not
acting as such it's just taking the
language that we've learned and using it
in a practical way if we do have
students who are extremely shy and don't
want to act is that we are happy to have
them direct
we always need directors and of course
script writers for the b12 levels and
above because they were over writing
your own script logo loses immersion
boku detective adenosine pomelo residue
Madonna poodle new technologies converge
waste such Panther science it's a belief
still vision and to focus on a service
comparing each back
[Applause]
you